et pour commenter cette grève des agents
de la police scientifique etc avec nous
michel laurens secrétaire national
adjoint du stimpack le syndicat national
indépendant des personnels
administratifs techniques et
scientifiques de la police nationale
bonjour monsieur lawrence merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors on l'a vu
à vous demander les mêmes droits que vos
collègues qualifié d' actifs une demande
qui n'est pas nouvelle non elle est
revendiquée depuis maintenant vraiment
fortement depuis trois ans en 2015 nous
avions déjà effectué une manifestation
sur paris et depuis l'année dernière le
1er janvier de l'année dernière déjà
nous avions fait une grève à la saint
sylvestre donc vraiment pour revendiquer
ce statut
parce qu'on est dans un métier qui a
évolué peut-être trop rapidement avec
des missions qui en a qui ont vraiment
été accentuée enfin voilà on a eu le
diversifier par rapport à ce qu'ils
étaient avant le métier et du coup on se
retrouve avec un statut qui est
totalement inadéquat par rapport aux
missions qu'on nous demande on a le même
costume mais pas les mêmes droits c'est
ce qu'a déclaré le secrétaire national
de votre syndicat pourquoi ces
différences au sein de la police
nationale est alors cette différence
historique 1 à la base on les les agents
qui est faisait la police scientifique
étaient des agents techniques de
laboratoire il y avait de la photo
argentique
on était beaucoup sur du labo et il ya
eu l'essor de la police scientifique
avec notamment la volonté qu'il ya des
actes de police technique et
scientifique sur tous les actes de
délinquance
classique devront dit la délinquance de
masse la petite et moyenne délinquance
et il ya eu aussi les évolutions
technologiques qui ont deux conduit à ce
que la police scientifique soit présente
sur tout type de scène d'infraction et
auparavant ça avait été fait par des
collègues actifs d'ailleurs les
gendarmes sont toujours ceux ci sur ce
système là où ce sont des gendarmes qui
effectuent ces opérations mais en police
il y avait eu un virage qui avait été
pris parce que on voit là c'est
historique
c est ce que le virage a été mal perçue
en tout cas sur cette cette évolution
est la diminution des effectifs
d'une manière générale dans la police
conduit aussi qu'il faut il faut
continuer la mission dont on comprend
avec les effectifs quand là et on a
donné on a chargé un petit peu la mule
sur la police scientifique
on se retrouve de plus en plus à faire
des actes qui s'apparente à la on peut
mettre sous scellés désormais on peut on
est surtout content je l'aï déjà dit on
est sur toutes les scènes plus imaginer
une scène d'infraction sans un acte de
police technique et scientifique
il ya eu aussi tout ce qui est
l'alimentation du fichier que ce soit
fneg final fight donc la génétique ou
les empreintes papillaires qui fait
aussi que nous sommes beaucoup plus
exposés qu'auparavant on prend les
empreintes de tout le monde donc on se
retrouve aussi dans notre vie privée
confronté à la délinquance au
délinquance à la personne qui était en
garde à vue qui avait acquis on a pris
ses empreintes son adn nous reconnaît au
quotidien comme étant policiers mais on
n'est pas policier et à la
reconnaissance de cette difficulté même
pendant les messieurs nos missions
on nous a dotés d'un gilet pare-balles
et à côté de cela on nous dit mais vous
me prenez aucun risque on se retrouve
comme ça dans cette ambiguïté que
conte revendiquant des gens il y en a
marre il faut qu'on prenne une décision
sur ce qu'est la police scientifique au
sein du ministère de l'intérieur au sein
de la police et dans ces conditions
c'est soit on nous retire voilà de
toutes ces missions on prend aucun
risque et en soit on est on fait partie
de la police
mais dans ces conditions nous donne un
statut qui soit en raccord parce que
pareil je vais préciser tout de suite on
a le droit de grève c'est ce qui nous
avait d'ailleurs été rétorqué qu'il
voulait pas nous retirer notre droit de
grève
or on l'a vu déjà l'année dernière et
encore plus la du mouvement qu'on a
lancé à trois semaines qui et qui a été
fortement suivie par les collègues
continuent d'être lui c'est que bas dès
qu'on met un service en croit nous
sommes réquisitionnés avec des motifs un
petit peu étrange notamment des
réquisitions sur trois semaines de temps
en vidant vous êtes réquisitionnés pour
faire votre travail quotidien et pas
pour une mission spécifique qui serait
un homicide quelque chose comme ça donc
on livre c'est ce qu'on essaie de mettre
en avant
il ya vraiment un statut qui n'est pas
adéquat ça ne va pas et la réforme des
retraites qui était aussi qui faisait
déjà partie une revendication puisqu'on
a un tir notre salaire qui était pas
pris en compte
pour vous qui n'est toujours pas pris en
compte pour la retraite du coup il venu
en plus alimentée c'est cette
frustration
justement concernant la réforme des
retraites on a vu plusieurs corps de
métiers ont réussi à obtenir
voilà le fait de conserver un régime
spécial c'est le cas d'ailleurs des
forces de l'ordre emmanuel macron lui a
rappelé que les dérogations régime
universel ne pouvait concerner que ceux
qui ont bénéficié déjà avant le projet
de réformes
ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas
justement c'est une sorte de fin de non
recevoir
on l'a perçu comme ça le courrier du 15
décembre 14 essence je sais plus excusez
moi pour ça qui a été donc diriger nos
collègues à mes camarades actifs nous
exclus de ce dispositif c'est bien
marqué d'ailleurs dans son courrier et
du coup c'est à ce moment là vraiment
que les collègues ont décidé de se
mettre en croît de 10 rebonds bas à
toutes les négociations que nous
essayons de mener depuis trois ans sont
ont trouvé une fin dans cette lettre
alors il ya une manifestation
aujourd'hui qui est prévue à paris
d'autres actions en région on l'a
précisé quels sont les autres actions
que vous pourriez prendre si jamais vous
n'êtes pas entendu il va y avoir on fait
beaucoup de choses parce que parce qu'on
a un sens du service public parce qu'on
veut que ça tourne parce qu'on s'imagine
pas que voilà il ya des victimes
et tout ça mais il ya des choses qui va
peut-être falloir qu'on arrête de faire
il ya de la disponibilité qu'on nous
demande si on est sédentaire on va
peut-être traitements disponibles
on a déjà mis en application il ya eu
des réquisitions d'ailleurs
comme je le vois là il y en a énormément
il ya eu énormément de pression c'est
sûr les collègues mais je pense qu'on va
devoir malheureusement entrer en conflit
avec nos propres hiérarchie qui essaie d
fois de nous mettre le sens du service
public
alors on parle de cela alors que je
pense qu'on a démontré depuis des années
qu'on veut qu'on a cet esprit on a
l'esprit police à dire qu'on veut la
résolution des enquêtes ont compensé
inscrire c'est un métier de passion que
ce soit que c'est pour les policiers les
pompiers
je pense que vous affirmez tout ça ce
sont des métiers quand même où on entre
on sait qu'on va en prendre la tête
plein parce qu'on vit des choses qui
sont difficiles on est là mais ça on est
prêts à les assumer
mais par contre il faut arrêter aussi de
nous culpabiliser là dessus on va
arrêter cela et on va d'ailleurs entamer
même des recours sur sur les
réquisitions qui ont été formulées et
oui le combat va être dur oc on est très
peu est ce qu'on trouve en plus le plus
absurde
alors il ya mes personnels l'aimé
personnel pendant mes camarades qui sont
administratif et technique aussi qui est
qui en pâtissent de cela il ya un combat
aussi amené avec eux pour leur pleine
reconnaissance dans le sein du ministère
de l'intérieur
mais voilà les policiers scientifiques
ne représente que 2500 agents ils sont
exposés
ils sont sur le terrain on a trouvé
énormément d'argent pour les peaux les
actifs etc environ ne demande même pas
une revalorisation de salaire on
essayait juste
enfin de trouver notre place au sein de
la police très bien en tout cas merci
beaucoup à monsieur michel laurens et
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national adjoint du jeu ce n'est pas le
syndicat national indépendant des
personnels administratifs techniques et
scientifiques de la multinationale
merci